bienvenue dans l'un des temples du
crémant de bourgogne plus de trois
millions de bouteilles sont sortis d'ici
en 2018
en dix ans la maison louis bouillot à
multiplier sa production par deux pour
répondre à une demande grandissante
l'engouement s'est confirmée pendant les
fêtes nous avons réussi à progresser et
faire progresser nos ventes de 250 mille
bouteilles cette année ce qui représente
environ + 11% sur nos ventes mais
principalement à l'export et sur des
marchés comme la scandinavie comme les
états unis le canada
l'ensemble de la filière connaît une
hausse des ventes de 4 et demi pour cent
environ en 2018
ce succès grandissant s'explique
peut-être par un nouveau positionnement
marketing
depuis trois ans les producteurs de
crémant de bourgogne ont de nouveau
label éminents et grands éminent il
désigne des vins d'exception plus cher
qui vinifie jusqu'à trois ans ça nous
rapproche un petit peu de la
classification
deux des appellations de bourgogne c'est
un petit peu l'idée mais c'est aussi
donner une clarté un petit peu aux
consommateurs quand il achète un crémant
que ça si tu es un petit peu quand ils
voient que ça sera signée emilio grand
éminent il sait qu'il aura affaire à un
produit un petit peu plus un petit peu
plus particulier plus travailler avec 19
millions de bouteilles produites le
crémant représentent aujourd'hui 10% de
la production viticole bourguignonne le
marché national reste encore
majoritaires mais on voit que la part à
l'exportation qui s'approche des 40%
aujourd'hui ne cesse de progresser et
ont rejoint quelque part la logique de
la bourgogne viticole
plus question de se penser en concurrent
du champagne vendues entre 6 et 20 euros
le crémant de bourgogne veut être
reconnu comme un grand vin de bourgogne